Quite a few of you guys have been asking us
to make a video on the real differences between
the iPhone 11 and the 11 Pro, so here it is!
As well as the question of which one of these
premium iPhones you should buy.
The answer actually boils down to something
very simple.
I’ll explain in just a bit.
If you’re a fan of colors, you get a lot
more options on the iPhone 11, while the 11
Pro is a bit more limited, but the new midnight
green color is much nicer than I expected.
On the back, they get a new unique square
bump that’s machined out of a single sheet
of glass, with the 11 getting two circular
camera bumps, while the 11 Pro gets a nicely
arranged 3 bumps that in my opinion, screams
premium.
More on those cameras in just a minute.
The Matte glass back looks really nice on
the 11 Pro, while the 11 gets a glossy back
with matte on the square bump.
I personally love the smooth finish of the
11 Pro’s matte glass, which is also very
fingerprint and microscratch resistant, but
others may not like how slippery it is and
they may prefer the iPhone 11 for the extra
grip in the hand.
The 11 Pro also has a glossy stainless steel
frame which feels very grippy and premium,
but it’s more susceptible to microscratches,
while the regular 11 has an aluminum frame
that Apple’s been using since the iPhone
6, but if you like to use a case with your
iPhone, the difference in feel won’t matter.
With last year’s iPhones, the XR was noticeably
thicker than the XS, but this year, the 11
Pro got a bit thicker, so you won’t really
notice a big difference in your hand like
you did last year.
The 11 Pro comes in two sizes, 5.8 inches,
which I personally feel is too small, and
6.5 inches, which is nice for the large display,
but a bit uncomfortable to hold in one hand.
So in my opinion, the 6.1” size of the Phone
11 is actually the perfect middle-ground,
offering a large display while feeling perfect
in the hand.
The iPhone 11 features the exact same LCD
display from last year’s XR, with less than
1080p resolution, which is a bummer, but you
can’t really tell with regular use unless
you pixel peep or watch a very high quality
video.
It’s got the same True Tone technology and
excellent color accuracy with P3 wide-color
gamut.
The iPhone 11 Pro’s display has a much higher
resolution, a much better contrast ratio thanks
to it being an OLED display, and it got even
brighter this year.
The main difference is that you can’t watch
high-quality HDR content on the regular 11,
and you’ll have more trouble seeing the
display when you’re outside in broad daylight.
The benefit of the iPhone 11 Pro’s OLED
display is that using dark mode or a darker
wallpaper will actually save battery life
because the individual pixels emit their own
light and can actually turn off completely
when displaying black.
One of the biggest downsides with last year’s
iPhone XR was that it didn’t get 3D Touch
like on the XS, but this year, even the 11
Pro doesn’t get it anymore.
Now the one display difference that matters
the most to me is that the display bezels
on the 11 are noticeably larger than the ones
on the 11 Pro, which already seem large compared
to other phones like the Note 10 Plus.
So with all of the visible differences out
of the way, let’s get into feature differences.
Something new this year is that the iPhone
11 Pro actually comes with an 18W fast-charger
in the box instead of the super old and slow
5w charger with the 11.
Now if the slow 5w charger is keeping you
from buying the iPhone 11, it shouldn’t.
The 11 actually supports the same exact fast-charging
speed as the 11 Pro, you just have to buy
the fast-charger separately, which unfortunately,
is about $30 from Apple.
Thankfully, you can buy a charger with the
same exact 18 watts of fast-charging speed
for only $16 right now on Amazon.
We’ll drop a link down below.
Now if I could explain the iPhone 11 Pro and
Pro Max in just two words, they would be battery
life.
My 11 Pro Max is the first phone I’ve ever
had where I can do anything on my phone and
no longer have to even think about battery
life.
It’s so great that I’ve actually stopped
checking it throughout the day.
Now the battery life on the 11 isn’t as
good, but it’s still rated for an extra
hour over the XR, which already had better
battery life than last year’s iPhone XS
Max, so it’s still pretty great.
The iPhone 11 Pro also gets better water resistance,
lasting 30 minutes in up to 13 feet of water,
which is more than the deepest point of a
regular swimming pool, while the 11 lasts
the same 30 minutes in up to 6 and a half
feet of water.
Other than all of that, and a couple of small
differences in the cameras, which I’ll mention
in a moment, everything else is basically
the same.
You get the same A13 Bionic chip, which is
the fastest processor on any smartphone, and
you even get the same 4GB of RAM, whereas
last year’s XR only got 3GB.
You get the same Face ID system, the same
U1 chip, the same spatial audio speakers with
Dolby Atmos support, the same WiFi 6 and Gigabit
LTE speed, the same Dual-Sim support, and
the same wireless charging speed.
And now for the cameras, you get the same
exact wide and ultrawide lenses.
The photos and videos coming out of these
two are literally identical, with the same
video recording features, the same crazy good
stabilization, night mode, 2nd gen smart HDR,
and basically every other feature available
on the 11 Pro.
However, the one thing the Pro has is the
telephoto lens.
And it’s good for a couple of things.
First is being able to zoom in more for photos
and videos, and second, you can take more
realistic close-up portrait photos.
If you try a close-up portrait on the iPhone
11’s wide lens, it greatly distorts the
shape of the face, so you have to take a step
back, snap the photo and then crop into it
in post to get a close-up, which can reduce
quality.
And that’s basically the only difference
in the cameras.
So if you’re still trying to figure out
if you should buy the iPhone 11 or the 11
Pro, I’ll make it really simple for you.
If you’re coming from a premium smartphone
that packs a high-quality OLED display, like
the iPhone X, you should go for the 11 Pro
or 11 Pro Max, because you’ll probably notice
the lack of contrast on the 11’s display,
as well as the thicker bezels.
But if you’re coming from an older LCD-packing
phone with large top and bottom bezels like
the iPhone 6, 7, or 8, then you should go
with the iPhone 11 and spend the extra $300-400
difference on something else, like a $16 fast-charger
by using the link in the description.
If you enjoyed this comparison, make sure
to Tap Like & click the circle above to subscribe.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next video!